familienministerin frau gefallen sie
sind eine der fleißigsten sie hauen
irgendwie einmal pro woche eine neue
gesetzesvorlage raus warum hat sich
dennoch an der situation der familien so
wenig geändert warum ist indes nicht
gelungen na ja ich sag mal ich bin jetzt
seit anderthalb jahren im amt und ich
habe mir ja aus der kommunalen erfahrung
in einem berliner brennpunkt bezirk
heraus vorgenommen dass wir den fokus
darauf legen für die kinder was zu tun
dem nicht ins wohlbehütete wohlstands
nest geboren sind 80 prozent der kinder
in deutschland geht es gut aber 20
prozent während eben gesehen brauchen
zusätzliche unterstützung sie bekommen
die teilweise aber wir müssen sagen es
ist eben manchmal schwierig dass kinder
auch alle leistungen auf diesen anspruch
ein recht haben auch wirklich bekommen
deswegen haben wir unser starkes
familiengesetz gemacht um das zu
vereinfachen zu entbürokratisieren
bildungs und teilhabepaket leichter
zugänglich zu machen und natürlich auch
so etwas zu machen wie der eine euro zum
mittagessen wird abgeschafft es gibt
zusätzliches schulstarterpaket es gibt
den die kostenfreie fahrkarte es gibt
den kinderzuschlag zusätzlich zum
kindergeld und wo ihre gesunde eltern
die ja klar für eltern die ihm nicht so
viel geld haben und wir haben auch
deutliche verbesserungen für
alleinerziehende dass es jetzt im sommer
in kraft getreten
und wir sind natürlich jetzt dabei dass
wir das auch unter die leute bringen
dass wir sagen ihr habt anspruch nimmt
denn an und die dinge zu vereinfachen
und wir werden nächstes jahr den
kinderzuschlag digital machen
das sind alles schritte um eben auch
eine künftige kindergrundsicherung
vorzubereiten die ja diese zeit
demokraten wollen für die wir auch ein
konzept dazu kommen wir noch das ist
erstmal ein großer strauß an maßnahmen
von denen manche eben leider auch noch
nicht mal wissen
vor allem dünger ist bei uns sie ist
präsidentin des wissenschaftszentrums
berlin für sozialforschung warum ist
sind überwiegend frauen von armut
betroffenen in deutschland mehr frauen
sind diejenigen die für die kinder nach
wie vor sorgen also wenn man sich die
teilzeitbeschäftigung beispielsweise
anschaut sind das neun von zehn
teilzeitbeschäftigten die frauen sind
und diese teilzeitbeschäftigung geht
eben mit verminderten
karrieremöglichkeiten denn hier geht mit
verminderten einkommen hier schafft
keine solide grundlage und von daher
wenn
frauen dann kinder haben wenn sie sich
um diese kinder auch kümmern möchten und
das möchte frauen wie auch männer mögen
auch aber meiner seite neben zelten
heraus darüber können wir nachher noch
reden sind sie eben jene die das leid zu
tragen haben und zwar nicht nur für eine
kurze zeit sondern wirklich für ihr
ganzes leben punkt bei uns ist johannes
vogel der sprecher für arbeitsmarkt-
sozial- und rentenpolitik der fdp
bundestagsfraktion
herr vogel ist die armut der frauen der
preis für die selbstverwirklichung der
männer so sollte es zumindest nicht sein
also ich glaube wenn wir darüber reden
es sind ja es sind ja nicht die kinder
die menschen arm machen sondern
arbeitslosigkeit macht menschen am
mangelnden bildungschancen machen
menschen arm verpasste oder versperrte
karrierewege machen menschen haben und
zu aufbringen kindern menschen dann in
die situation insbesondere frauen so und
wenn wir das angehen wollen glaube ich
müssen wir drei dinge machen erstens
muss sich in der gesellschaft und in den
unternehmen was ändern also um es mal
ganz als der einzige mann in der runde
ganz klar zu sagen wir kommen auch ja
ich war nicht sehr oft genug andersrum
in st
auch männer müssen sich um kleine kinder
kümmern punkt wir brauchen echte gleiche
verteilung der arbeit zweitens wir
brauchen wirkliche vereinbarkeit bessere
betreuungsmöglichkeiten ist unser
flexiblere öffnungszeiten der kitas das
ist es ja was in der wurst in der
realität krank und für diejenigen wo es
eben schwierig ist was freigeben gesagt
hat glaube ich können wir nur
sozialstaat aber auch noch sehr viel
einfacher machen also wenn ich den
kritischen satz sagen darf starke
familien gesetzt das ist ein großer name
ob es ein großer wurf ist da melde ich
mal zweifel anwalt machen was man einem
einem ganz konkreten beispiels gerade
alleinerziehende es ist noch häufiger
konstellation heute in unserem land die
kriegen kinderzuschlag von der
familienkasse die kriegen wohngeld von
der kommunalen wohnungsbau kriegen
teilweise unterhaltsvorschuss von den
jugendämtern die kriegen bildung zu
teilhabe von den jobcentern vier
sozialleistungen mit unterschiedlichen
anrechnungsmöglichkeiten
bewilligungszeitraum
mitwirkungspflichten also ein chaos hier
blickt jetzt schon keiner mehr durch die
schicken die bürger von amt zu amt und
gerade bei alleinerziehenden ist das
finde ich keine zu
eine unmöglichkeit und da müssen wir
großen wurf machen oder sozialstaat
modernisieren da ist die idee ihres
gewichts an die box gehen sie sind die
familienpolitische sprecherin der fdp in
nordrhein westfalen hat roberto rick die
afg sagt am besten ist es für kinder
wenigstens die ersten drei jahre zu
hause zu bleiben wenn die mütter dann
aber zu hause sind und nicht arbeiten
wie kommen manche familien dann aus
dieser armutsfalle überhaupt irgendwann
raus glauben sie ja das ist genau das
ist ja das problem
das was wir auch immer wieder
programmieren dass es eigentlich bei
ganz vielen auch heute noch mehr hat
seine shell studie beispielsweise ja
auch gesehen dass selbst in den
heranwachsenden generationen von dem er
jetzt ja nicht wirklich sagen kann dass
sie mit wahnsinnig tradierten
rollenbildern aufgewachsen sind es immer
noch ganz stark der wunsch ist bei einem
kleinkind selber auch die betreuung zu
übernehmen
löwenanteil aller jungen frauen wünscht
sich dass auch nach wie vor
und die ist situation ist ebenso wenn
was machen dann haben wir und ich bin
die frau vorher berufstätig war dann
bekommt sie hat ein jahr elterngeld wenn
sie dann in gegebenenfalls einen beruf
zurückkehren muss als teilzeitkraft klar
dann wissen wir dass genau ich habe es
bei mir selber ja auch erlebt dann kann
man beim nächsten rentenbescheid schon
sehen wie sich die rente fast halbiert
wenn wir dann zu wenn man zurückkehrt in
dem beruf gesagt in teilzeit
gegebenenfalls auch ein zweites kind
möchte dann ist beim nächsten elterngeld
ja schon das bezieht sich wieder nur
noch auf das teilzeit gehalt und so
kannibalisieren sich im prinzip die
einkünfte unmittelbar mit dem
älterwerden und wahrscheinlich haben
sich dass die mütter und väter
irgendwann mal ganz anders vorgestellt
und die wie die flexibilität die ist ja
auch wenn das kind vier oder fünf oder
sechs jahre alt ist nicht mehr so
gegeben man hat ja auch einen haushalt
zu führen und völlig unabhängig davon ob
vater und mutter sich das teilen heißt
das also die die arbeitszeit die dieser
eltern leisten können die ist natürlich
geringer man hat auch den fokus einfach
woanders man möchte ja auch für die
kinder da sein also es ist ja nicht nur
eine bürde weil man eigentlich viel
lieber nur noch arbeiten möchte und dann
irgendwie das kind zu versorgen hat
sondern man wird das dann in der regel
auch wenn man sein kind liebt und auch
so eine vorstellung davon hatte wie es
ist familie zu leben und genau das darf
nicht sein unserer meinung nach dass ich
das so auswirkt
es ist eine katastrophe das erleichtert
auch nicht die entscheidung für kinder
und schon mal gar nicht von zweites oder
drittes kind
neben ihnen sitzt eine unternehmerin
marie christine ostermann frau ostermann
sie haben einen großhandel für
lebensmittel in der nähe von hamm 200
mitarbeiter 40 prozent davon sind frauen
warnen sie ihre kolleginnen ihre
mitarbeiterinnen eigentlich vor dem
risiko teilzeit also die situation dass
wir über teilzeit sprechen ist
eigentlich immer der fall wenn jemand
schwanger ist und in dem moment sprechen
wir natürlich dann nicht über das risiko
von armut sondern wir freuen uns erstmal
absolut dass die person ein kind
erwartet weil es einfach es ist was
total schön ist und ja auch einfach
super wichtig für unser land für unsere
zukunft das weiter kinder hier
willkommen geheißen werden und und auch
mit dazugehören und hier auch gut
aufwachsen können und dann diskutieren
wir als nächstes dann wie die zukunft
aussieht dann sagen die frauen manchmal
auch männer wenn die zu hause bleiben ab
und zu kommt das dann auch vor wie lange
sie eben dann zu hause bleiben wollen um
sich um das kind zu kümmern ein zwei
oder drei jahre und meine nächste frage
ist dann natürlich sofort ja wann wollen
sie wiederkommen und was können wir
machen dass sie möglichst früh auch
zurück in das unternehmen kommen denn in
zeiten des fachkräftemangels bin ich
natürlich auch sehr gute arbeitskräfte
egal ob mann oder frau darauf angewiesen
und das ist meistens so dass die frauen
nur in teilzeit zurückkommen wollen was
ich emotional gut nachvollziehen kann
ich kann das gut verstehen dass jemand
zeit mit seinem kind verbringen möchte
das ist natürlich auch sehr wichtig dass
die eltern sich intensiv um ihre kinder
kümmern
aber es ist einfach für unser
unternehmen für den arbeitsmarkt auch
extrem wichtig dass eben frauen und
männer auch gerne in vollzeit zurück in
die berufe kommen und ich habe den
eindruck durch die erfahrungen bei den
mitarbeitern im unternehmen und auch in
meinem privaten umfeld das kita
betreuung auch für kleine kinder auch in
einem sehr jungen alter auch im alter
von einem jahr zum beispiel sich sehr
sehr positiv auswirkt und die kinder
einfach extrem viel
zusätzlich zu dem lernen dass
zu hause lernen das kann man als eltern
teilweise gar nicht bieten was die
guitar anbieten bildung möglich ändern
den einen platz bekommen ich möchte die
runde gerne erweitern teilzeit und kita
plätze sind nur zwei von ein paar
problemen
die frauen haben bei uns ist heute abend
viel linke sie sind mutter von linke von
zwei kindern sie sind alleinerziehend
und sie haben unter anderem
demonstrationen gegen kinderarmut
organisiert in dieser schönen stadt
berlin
wie oft ist meine erste frage hat es in
ihrer familie zum leben kaum gereicht
also es gab schon immer wieder mal
probleme die ersten tauchten auf kurz
nach der trennung ich war damals noch im
studium ich wollte eigentlich mein
studium beenden und hatte dann aber auch
die möglichkeit nicht mehr
das war damals auch die umstellung von
den magister studiengänge auf die
bachelor studiengänge damals die
bologna-reform und ich bin dann joggen
gegangen um einfach nicht aus dem
studiensystem herauszufallen in den
studienplatz zu erhalten weil ich immer
dachte ich schaffe es noch es war aber
nicht möglich und das war so eine zeit
wo ich dann tatsächlich teilweise mit
der familie unter dem hartz-iv-satz auch
geblieben bin
es war eine sehr schwere zeit und habe
dann aber auch irgendwann mal aufgegeben
habe gesagt geh ich melde mich
arbeitslos oder arbeitssuchend und hab
dann aber auch keine jobs gefunden ich
habe wurde und ari rath gemacht während
des studiums auch schon und dabei die
journalistin nichts mehr gefunden mit
zwei kleinen kindern das war dann sehr
schwierig und ich habe dann eine
umschulung angeboten bekommen
damals vom jobcenter habe das auch
gemacht ja und dann gab es immer wieder
so fallstricke wo man gemerkt hat okay
ich habe dann angefangen vollzeit zu
arbeiten
dann kam eine
dann fiel der unterhaltsvorschuss weg
als familienpolitische leistungen und so
habe ich eigentlich so alles mal
beantragt und ich hatte da man nun alles
durch ich habe alles durch und ich kann
wirklich sagen was uns fehlt als an eine
szene ist eine planungssicherheit
sie haben der vater der kinder konnte
sie nicht beteiligen an der
kindererziehung weil durch krankheit
davon gehindert war jetzt erleben sie
natürlich auch frau linke dass die
politik wahnsinnig viele versprechungen
macht sind in bezug auf die familie in
bezug auf die kinder hatten sie
eigentlich jemals das gefühl dass mit
dem wort familie auch sie persönlich
gemeint war
also ich habe mich schon auch mit meinen
kindern immer als familie gesehen und
ich empfinde das natürlich auch so an
eine ziele und ihre kinder sind familie
aber ich habe schon auch den eindruck
gewonnen
durch die erfahrungen die ich halt jetzt
doch in 14 jahren gesammelt habe
das alleine von der gesellschaft und
auch von der politik nicht unbedingt als
familie gesehen werden
sie haben später als die kinder haben
sie gerade schon gesagt größer waren
eine ausbildung gemacht und haben
teilzeitarbeit begonnen das machen sie
auch heute noch
worauf hoffen sie also ich hab jetzt in
erster linie auch mal auf einen
vollzeit-job wieder weil die kinder sind
groß ich kann mehr machen ich könnte mir
arbeiten und ja ich brauche jetzt
einfach nur die möglichkeit das eben
auch umzusetzen genau
aber weil ich eben seit 2008 zehn also
seit anfang dieses jahres haben wir auch
die möglichkeit den job zu reduzieren
stunden mäßig und dann irgendwann wieder
aufzustocken
aber das hat mich jetzt zum beispiel
nicht weil ich vorher schon reduziert
weil sie vorher schon reduziert waren
und man muss es an sagen dass eben in
dieses berühmte brücken geld hinein
komfort linke klasse dass wir sie heute
bei uns haben bitte kommen sie mit in
die runde und schon geht
einen
vor allen dingen wenn die
gesetzesvorhaben von frau gefallen also
beispielsweise die ganztagsschule oder
aber die verpflichtende kita schon eine
pflichten die kita ist ein paar jahre
früher auf den weg gebracht worden wären
hätte es frau linke dann einfach mit
sicherheit und ich könnte auch mehr
mitgehen wenn man immer sagt frauen
wollen nicht vollzeit arbeiten weil ich
schon probleme habe wenn die
rahmenbedingungen so gar nicht sind dass
man vollzeit erwarten tätig sein kann
dass man dann sagt die frauen möchten
das ja gar nicht genau so wie ich ein
problem damit habe entschuldigung wenn
man sagt wir wissen ja dass es besser
ist für die kinder wenn die mütter drei
jahre zu hause bleiben da gibt es ganz
viele studien die das zeigt dass es
überhaupt nicht so ist
und wenn das so ist dann geht es oft die
kosten der kinder weil die kinder
freiheit weil sie sachsen es eben so
dass es dann für die kinder doch besser
ist und wir haben ja grosse erfahrungen
damit gemacht dass es für die kinder oft
überhaupt nicht gut ist war gerade
kinder die aus familien kommen wenige
einbildung mitbringen denn diejenigen
sind die am wenigsten in diese
kinderbetreuungseinrichtungen gehen und
davon dann auch am wenigsten profitieren
können und von daher sich dann so einen
ganzen blumenstrauß von armut aufmacht
wir reden jetzt sei er impliziert alle
über finanzielle armut aber für mich ist
armut natürlich auch bildungsarmut für
mich ist armut auch wohnungs armut und
dann müssen wir differenzieren und
schauen wie stark diese armuts formen
zusammenhängen
manchmal fallen sie sich aufs schlimmste
aber manchmal können wir auch so
interpretieren dass wir zumindest diese
kinder dann nicht auch so langfristig
bildungsarmen kindern aufgefallen
nochmal zu dem beispiel von frau linken
die gesetze die da jetzt auf dem tisch
lägen respektive auf den weg gebracht
worden sind die helfen den kindern von
frau linke nicht mehr diesen 15 und 16
können sie ihr trotzdem noch auf gut
machen na ja zunächst einmal bei 15 und
16 jährigen kindern
wir haben ja ein verändertes
unterhaltsvorschuss gesetzt der
unterhaltsvorschuss ist ja vom
lebensalter der wurde früher bis zum
zwölften lebensjahr gewährt jetzt wird
er bis zum
lebensjahr gewährt da gehe ich mal davon
aus dass sie davon profitieren
und das sind bei zwei kindern mehrere
hundert euro im monat so dass das schon
auch ein deutlicher schritt für die
alleinerziehende das was wir zum sommer
gemacht haben ist wir haben gesagt der
kinderzuschlag also der zuschlag zum
kindergeld den menschen mit kleinen
einkommen bekommen
es gibt also kindergeld wohngeld dann
bekommen sie diesen kinderzuschlag
poopzkid den gab es bisher für die
alleinerziehende nicht weil er
angerechnet wurde auf den
unterhaltsvorschuss das passiert jetzt
nicht mehr da wird nur noch zum teil
angerechnet so dass sie den
kinderzuschlag auch bekommen können wenn
sie ein zu geringes einkommen haben
das heißt man hat dann im zweifel
kindergeld wohngeld unterhaltsvorschuss
und den kinderzuschlag das sind viel
leistung sie haben recht das ist
natürlich auch kompliziert aber erstmal
klar geht es einfacher das ist ja auch
die zielsetzung ich kann ja erst mal nur
sagen was ist die gesetzeslage die wir
im moment haben und die ist so dass es
schon mehrere auch finanzielle
unterstützungsleistungen für allein als
inne und auch gerade für familien gibt
und das sind mehrere hundert euro zumal
mit dem gute kita gesetz jetzt auch noch
geregelt haben dass diejenigen die
wohngeld oder kinderzuschlag bekommen
oder sozialleistungen grundsätzlich
überall in deutschland von den kita
gebühren zu befreien sind das kann auch
mehrere hundert euro mehr im monat
ausmachen
das ziel muss aber sein wir haben über
die jahre eine sammlung von
verschiedensten familienleistung das
vision schreiben dass wo immer was
angebaut wurde
und wir müssen an einen punkt kommen wo
wir sagen es muss so sein dass alle
diese leistungen gebündelt werden zu
einer geldleistung zu einem neuen
kindergeld wo wir davon ausgehen dass
wir sagen es gibt für alle kinder in
deutschland
auch für die kinder die jetzt noch in
hartz4 sind kinder sind keine kleinen
langzeitarbeitslosen ja die gehören raus
aus hartz 4 und da müssen wir sagen für
alle gibt es ein basis beträgt erstmal
sicher ist wer moment 17,8 millionen
kinder in deutschland die kindergeld
bekommen also und jugendliche bis zum 25
lebensjahr und für die muss es ein
verlässlicher gerechte sicheren betrag
geben und wir als sozialdemokraten sehen
dass du dass er der bei 250 euro liegen
müsste und dass wir dann einen
zusatzbetrag gewähren abhängig vom
einkommen der eltern niedriger ist ist
der betrag genau wenn wir sl
wie ein kongress ist jetzt der jüngste
vorschlag der spd damit wir da jetzt
nicht durcheinanderkommen nämlich für
eine kinder gewohnt bestehen müssen da
würde ich gerne an das amt über superman
dinger sagte eine gute kinder wollen
sich unter zu gut ist nicht nur ich gebe
geld in die familien sondern ich gebe
auf der einen seite finanzielle
unterstützung aber auf der anderen seite
gehört die infrastruktur dazu und das
heißt gute kinderbetreuung in kitas und
horte errichten das mir sehr wichtig
dass wir eben dass beide sehen
infrastruktur und bloß eine sichere
verlässliche betrag okay dann sind wir
jetzt traurig danielewski nochmal bei
der frage das natürlich nur wenn kinder
auch gut betreut sind wir eine frau sie
sich nicht ich überhaupt traut arbeiten
zu gehen und in ruhe arbeiten zu gehen
ist an dieser einschätzung irgendwas
falsch
also ich möchte mal an zwei punkten ein
haken an der stelle also zum einen wurde
ja gerade angesprochen dass das die
frauen ja gar nicht die freie
entscheidung haben voll berufstätig zu
sein weil die rahmenbedingungen gerade
was die kinderbetreuung eben mangelhaft
ist und weil er mit fokus auf der
anderen seite haben sie aber auch nicht
die freie wahl zu hause zu bleiben weil
in der regel der einkommens- druck so
groß ist also im prinzip ist es ein
dilemma weder in die eine noch in die
andere richtung und das ist
unbefriedigend das ist das ist das halt
was wir programmieren und auf jeden fall
zu der qualität in den kitas ich kann
das gut nachvollziehen dass man sagt auf
frühkindliche bildung ist wichtig gerade
für kinder die vielleicht zu hause eben
nicht so die förderung bekommen
wir haben zahlreiche anhörungen dazu
auch im landtag gab noch viele experten
und das geht uns natürlich auch na das
ist ja jetzt nicht so als würde ich
sagen ja dann sollte man schon zu hause
bleiben und wenn sie vom fernseher
versauern dann ist uns das egal das ist
natürlich quatsch aber die bertelsmann
stiftung beispielsweise hat jetzt bei
der großen anhörung eben zur kibiz
reform auch nochmal bestätigt dass die
personallage eigentlich so angespannt
ist an den in den kitas das aktuell nach
wissenschaftlichen maßstäben eben der
bildungserfolg fraglich ist
beziehungsweise dass man davon ausgehen
muss dass so dass der personalschlüssel
so schlecht ist dass die kinder eben
nicht profitieren und gerade die kinder
die vielleicht eine besondere förderung
bedürfen
die würden doch auch viel mehr davon
profitieren wenn sie eben auch eine
intensivere betreuung in den kitas bekam
und dann wäre es vielleicht schon
vorteilhaft wenn die kinder die
vielleicht auch zu hause unter drei sehr
gut aufgehoben werden wo die mütter
vielleicht eigentlich auch wollen aber
eben aus den finanziellen gründen nicht
machen dann ist ja trotzdem interessant
sehr vogel ist gleich daran dass
offensichtlich ihre parteikollegin
beatrix von storch eine sehr klare
meinung hat weil sie weiß wie es im
statut will mütter am liebsten
abschaffen und durch den staat ersetzen
hier seien die kinder zu hause betreuen
möchte macht sich fast schon verdächtig
das ideal ist heute die rund um
staatliche ganztagsbetreuung und
ganztags indoktrination so ganz
sportlich gefragt kommen sie zu
derselben einschätzung
also ich würde das mit sicherheit etwas
differenzierter betrachten frau von
storch hat glaube ich meiner kenntnis
nach auch selber keine kinder und kind
vielleicht das gitter leben auch nicht
so gut aus der eigenen erfahrung aber
nichtsdestotrotz das wurde also zugeben
ja also was soll der quatsch aber
nichtsdestotrotz was man kritisch
betrachten kann ist das natürlich je
mehr wenn die kinder acht stunden oder
noch länger am tag in der kita sind
haben natürlich auch die erzieherin und
die ausrichtung der kita einen einfluss
auf die entwicklung des kindes und wenn
ich als mutter dann abends mein kind nur
noch quasi zu bett bringe und morgens
der hinfahrt 23 stunden vom tage übrig
bleiben dass mein einfluss
gegebenenfalls schwinden kann das ist
auch richtig und dass wir da gerade in
gesellschaftsstrukturen die die anders
waren auch immer negative erfahrungen
damit gemacht haben ob das in
sozialistischen staaten ist oder sonst
wer wir sind
in der option also ich habe noch einmal
linke auch sie haben ihre kinder ja eher
die betreuung gegeben frau linke sind
sie eine rabenmutter haben sind toll
dass das haben oder beziehungsweise
kabinen wahrscheinlich keine schlechten
eltern sind und ich glaube das ist auch
gut ist natürlich kinder zur
selbstständigkeit zu erziehen
ich glaube auch dass meine kinder in den
einrichtungen in den see band mit
aufgehoben waren aber ich kann jetzt zum
beispiel auch mal ein beispiel sagen aus
der ganztagsbetreuung in der
grundschulzeit
da war es dann schon so dass das auch
nicht mehr so wirklich passend war also
da habe ich dann auch zum beispiel das
war dann auch der punkt wo ich reduziert
habe weil er sich irgendwann haben das
ist ihnen nicht gut tut sie es lieber
anders organisiert ich genau warum herr
vogel aber auch daran warum gibt es
nicht beruf und gleichzeitig familie
warum ist das verschreckt ja also ich
glaube jetzt kommen zwei dinge zusammen
wieder ist aber so einmal natürlich die
frage moderne rollenverteilung in den
partnerschaften da wo wir die
partnerschaft haben dann zweitens
brauchen wir eine infrastruktur die das
auch möglich macht also das eine ist
dass es genug kita plätze gibt es andere
ist dass die zum beispiel das ist kein
banaler punkt öffnungszeiten haben die
auch realistisches und berufsleben passt
wäre ja so und das riesenproblem in der
in der realität deswegen an der stelle
ich sind sehr gut dass der bund da geld
gibt in nrw zum beispiel pak nochmal
landes geld obendrauf überall will das
zweitgrößte bundesland nicht alle länder
machen dass manche länder stecken es nur
in die beitragsfreiheit ich glaube es
muss auch in die qualität der kitas
gehen weil ich ja aber es gibt auch
länder die mac nur puppen die packen's
komplett in die in die beitragsfreiheit
es ja auch egal
in nordrhein westfalen zum beispiel über
eine milliarde in die qualität das heißt
dass mehr erzieher flexiblere
öffnungszeiten genau darum geht es
drittens geht es aber auch und da sie
waren so schön differenziert wird direkt
aber leider im landtag nrw machen sie es
anders da geht es ja auch um die frage
hören wir endlich auf leuten einzureden
es sei ein problem die kinder früh in
die kita zu geben
sie haben das im landtag beantragt in
nordrhein westfalen ganz konkret wo sie
sagen aussagen
ins parlament bringen wo dann drin steht
ja es würde den kindern schaden und das
finde ich müssen wir auch durchbrechen
rabenmutter dieses wort gibt es übrigens
nur um deutschen nach meiner kennt kann
ihnen sagen die qualitäten der leiste
aber dafür brauchen wir eben auch eine
politische politischen konsens dass wir
es ernsthaft allen menschen mit kindern
überlassen selber zu entscheiden wie sie
es machen wollen und werden wir
entscheiden können ja dann auch eine
materielle freiheit nicht entscheiden
wenn ich wenn beide ein wenn beide
elternteile arbeiten gehen müssen weil
sie sonst gar nicht wissen wie sie ihre
wohnung bezahlen sollen weil sonst die
rate vom auto nicht mehr bezahlen können
wenn beide arbeiten gehen müssen können
wir nicht von einer wahlfreiheit
sprechen sie schon mal die wahl hat
reden wenn ganz in der realität sehr oft
die mütter die jungen frauen sich in
wahrheit immer noch gesellschaftlichen
druck ausgesetzt sehen und dazu gehört
eben auch dass sie in den landtag
anträge einbringen wo dann steht würde
den kindern schaden wenn sie betreut
werden das ist gegenteil von moderner
gesellschaftspolitik und der anderen
aus frankreich nach belgien nach
dänemark da ist das könnte eine stelle
beide arbeiten vollzeit geht's unser
vater den kindern in müssen wir sind
glücklich ich finde auch dass es wichtig
ist dass die eltern wahlfreiheit haben
und aus meiner beruflichen erfahrung
habe ich oft die erfahrung gemacht dass
eltern wirklich auch frei entscheiden
und selber wirklich auch sagen ich
möchte mich auch viel mit um das kind
kümmern und wähle deswegen die
teilzeitvariante ja das ist einfach
gefragt es muss mit dazugehören und
trotzdem vor allem endinger noch mal die
frage will der staat den müttern die
kinder wegnehmen will der staat die
erziehung bestimmen gibt es eine
ganztags indoktrination laien ganz im
gegenteil der staat jetzt jedoch viel
dass die mütter zu hause bleiben
also nehmen sie mal das
ehegattensplitting beispielsweise und
unglaubliches anreizsystem dass eine
person weniger arbeitet als die andere
männer sind meistens ein bisschen älter
sind ein bisschen etablierter in ihrer
karriere
also machen verdienen mehr weil sie in
den entsprechenden berufen sind also
arbeiten die männer rein ökonomische
verhandlungs prinzipien im haushalt wenn
er arbeitet weiter frau reduziert
ehegattensplitting tritt ein mann hat
das entsprechende geldern als steuer
ersparnis wundern sich ist diese wurden
dann wird immer dicker und immer dicke
und dann kommt man nicht mehr auf den
karriere war dann macht man was anderes
dann hat mir keinen ausbildungs system
welches dann wirklich noch mal eine
zweite oder dritte ausbildungs finde ich
super dass sie das gemacht haben aber es
ist denn da eine ausnahme viele schaffen
es nicht eine zweite oder dritte
ausbildung nach einer solchen erfahrung
und einem abgebrochenen das leben die
ich klasse
aber ich möchte noch mal auf ne wirklich
prinzipielle frage zurück gehen nämlich
ob wir wirklich als das familie und das
ist auch eine frage an die ministerin
ich glaube wir haben das nie diskutiert
wohin wir eigentlich wollen bezüglich
der des umfangs der erwerbsarbeit
ja wir haben immer gesagt eigentlich
reicht im idealfall die eine
erwerbsarbeit um den ganzen haushalt zu
füttern und zu ernähren und so etwas
dann hat sich das zu einer zuarbeit von
frauen entwickelt und jetzt gehen wir
davon aus dass bei
vollzeit erwerbstätig sind das finde ich
schon ein problem weil es so viel
anderes im leben gibt ausbildungen es
gibt die pflege der eltern und so
warum gehen wir nicht zu einem bild wo
wir sagen wir arbeiten jetzt als normal
32 stunden frauen wie männer
dann haben wir auch nicht die arbeiten
sei differenzierung wir haben nicht das
alles auf kosten der frauen wie wir sie
im moment haben wir machen das über den
lebensverlauf verteilt manchmal mehr
manchmal weniger schneiden rentenzugang
flexibel
ich finde man sollte in solche
richtungen denken die dann auch arbeit
und leben vielen wenn leblich und
einfacher maschinist individuellen
mittel erhalte ist überholt finde ich
ihn ist ja eine frage ob wir die arbeit
fair verteilt haben zwischen männern und
frauen vor allen dingen die arbeit die
sich dann auch später lohnt wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden habe mal nach der
reihe nach vor wir müssen jetzt ein
bisschen ordnen das was frau direkt an
iloxx gesagt dieses modell der
großfamilie wo die generationen
füreinander einstehen wo alt und jungen
zusammen füreinander da sind ist das ein
altes modell ist das vergleich nein ich
glaube dass es diese modelle gibt auf
jeden fall die werden ja auch gelebt es
ja auch schön aber wir müssen auch mal
zur kenntnis nehmen dass es viele
menschen gibt die leben nicht am
gleichen ort wie ihre eltern
die können das nicht so machen das
geheim war für oma und opa quasi zur
verfügung steht und es gibt menschen und
das finde ich das muss man auch mal in
der diskussion sagen die sehr wohl wie
partnerschaften wo beide wollen dass
familie und beruf vereinbar sind und das
hinzubekommen dafür die voraussetzung zu
schaffen das eben
ich sag mal wir haben so viele tolle
frauen die super qualifiziert sind die
können wir nicht einfach für jahre vom
auch aus dem gesellschaftlichen aus dem
arbeitsleben rausnehmen mit der
begründung
naja das ist eben so und wir leben ein
bestimmtes familienbild ich glaube dass
es wichtig ist zu ermöglichen dass alle
das leben können was sie wollen und
trotzdem muss man fragen wer bezahlt das
alles mehr hat letztens im münsterland
eine mutter gesagt wissen sie wie sie
die kinder krise ganz leicht lösen
können
bezahlen mehr einfach lässt sich die
ersten fünf bis zehn jahren mit meinem
kind zu hause bleiben kann
das kann man so diskutieren nur ich
frage mich natürlich schon wäre es dann
eigentlich alles bezahlt und wie wir es
dann machen und wir brauchen eine hohe
erwerbsquote alle und wir brauchen auch
die möglichkeit dass menschen die im
beruf erlernt haben denen studium
gemacht haben eine ausbildung dass die
sich auch verwirklichen können im beruf
und das sieht das nicht unter dem
verzicht auf kinder tun müssen sondern
dass sie beides können und dafür na klar
ist flexibilisierung der arbeitszeit
home office möglichkeiten mobiles
arbeiten diese dinge neue moderne
modelle sind nötig und natürlich auch
die betreuungs englische ich kann das
ganz langsam nrw also werden sie damit
nimmt ganztagsangebote ich höre da ganz
viele menschen eltern die sagen wir
wollen das gerne
wir wollen nicht wenn das kind aus der
kita kommt und in klasse eins in der
grundschule anfängt dass dann das heißt
ja mittags ist schluss und dann ist das
kind auf sich gestellt das geht
natürlich und dann brauch ist die
angebote die eben auch am nachmittag
noch da sind und die zur verfügung
stehen nicht verpflichtend aber als
möglichkeit damit menschen das machen
gehört sie da unterscheiden